spray Oh God may the words of my mouth
and the meditation of each one of our
hearts be acceptable in your sight oh
god you are our rock and our Redeemer
amen Monday februari 21st 2011 New
Orleans Louisiana backseat of a taxi
from lively Bourbon Street back to my
hotel I'm not going to try to imitate
New Orleans accent so bear with me cab
driver what kind of work do you do
always a tricky question you never know
where this will lead I'm a chaplain so
you work with people in the hospital
actually college students long pause cab
driver I wouldn't think they'd have any
need for a chaplain I sort of made a
curious noise and he carried on doesn't
seem like they'd have many problems
being college students he seemed to be
asking what would students possibly have
to worry about and I can imagine the
context for him asking this question as
a cab driver working the night shift in
New Orleans he is starting to see and
has seen many many times before the
throngs of college students headed down
for spring break sometimes when they get
in his cab they're sober mostly though
they're not and he told stories about
people piling into his cab and having no
idea what hotel they were supposed to go
back to no cares in the world and he is
a resident of New Orleans City destroyed
recently and crawling slowly back to
life so i can imagine these perspectives
might lead him to ask what
bleeeeegh could be worrying for college
students jesus said no one can serve two
masters you cannot serve God and wealth
do not worry about your life what you
will eat what you will drink or your
body what you aware you of little faith
so do not worry about tomorrow for
tomorrow will bring worries of its own
today's trouble is enough for today if I
could ask each of you what you are
worried about I'm willing to bet one of
the most common responses might be money
there are many others of course it's
midterm time it's also job interview
time and even last week during our
prayers of the people we heard about
many many troubling health situations in
people's lives grandparents medical
diagnosis all sorts of things weighing
on us but if we're honest don't we spend
a lot of time working for looking for
striving for fighting about wandering
about worrying about money in today's
Gospel text Jesus asks us to think hard
about where we put our trust one dollar
bill any dollar bill really in god we
trust our money says but too often the
gospel convicts in money we trust worry
about money is a constant for many and
for good reason things are really tight
right now if you're lucky enough to have
a job it might feel less than secure if
you're fortunate enough to get a
paycheck it might never seem like quite
enough if your student loans might be
piling up and so the pressure to get a
well-paying job is higher than ever and
if you're looking for a job or wondering
where your next meal is coming from
anxiety becomes the blood pulsing
through your body
the problem with Jesus command not to
worry is that it brings more worried
greg carey asks what leads to anxiety
more than forbidding it telling people
not to be anxious it's like telling them
not to think of an elephant don't think
about an elephant don't think about how
huge an elephant is or how gray its skin
is or how wrinkled or its long trunk
don't think about that don't worry so we
can understand this passage is telling
us that worry is bad unnecessary or a
reflection of our really struggling
faith and so we beat up on ourselves for
worrying and then we worry about how
much we're worrying and we missed the
point another misunderstanding of this
passage is that Jesus would want us to
be poor that poverty is glorified that
if someone has no money they must be
more free than to praise God sure
simplicity can be a virtuous way to live
but voluntarily living more simply is
different than living in poverty of
course struggling to find enough food
living without shelter or healthcare
this is not about a bank account balance
it's about our hearts if we approach
life only looking through the lens of
money then we have forgotten the source
of all good and all of our striving to
make money we have forgotten to strive
for God while Jesus spoke these words
about money in particular the command
not to worry can be applied to many
areas of our lives these words can offer
comfort to our friends when they're
weighed down with worry but another
danger is using this passage as a big
old band-aid think about a friend who is
anxious or worrying these days our first
impulse is to make her or him feel
better right to take away the worry and
so we want to say don't worry about that
exam don't worry about that medical test
don't worry about all the work you have
do don't worry that your parents are
splitting up God has it all under
control but if these words are said
before we deeply listen to someone's
concerns we are not really helping them
worry can be a sign of other big things
going on we might be able to help our
friends find some other support chronic
anxiety can be paralyzing to be helped
sometimes by scripture and also
sometimes by counseling or other
resources so before offering the good
news of the anti worried gospel close
your mouth and listen for a while listen
deeply to the one who is worrying
otherwise the worry just gets silenced
but we feel better having smeared the
balm of God's love over those wounds
that can be a little dangerous Jesus
command not to worry and to have my
heart in the right place makes me
realize how far astray I go sometimes
giving up on worry seems to be giving up
on control a prayer of confession that
many of you might be familiar with
begins this way we confess that we are
captive to sin and cannot free ourselves
so it is with money we are captive to
money and cannot free ourselves it
really doesn't matter how much or little
each of us has still holds true how much
time and energy do you spend thinking
and worrying about money and how much
time and energy do you spend God captive
to money we cannot free ourselves
Matthew Meyer Bolton puts it this way we
can on at the same time trust ultimately
in our own economic striving as the
bedrock foundation of our basic
well-being and trust ultimately in God
as that bedrock foundation we can only
really have one foundation to say it
another way is God the last resort or
first call if we are in bondage to money
and cannot free ourselves the good news
today is that Jesus frees us no Jesus
will not pay your credit card balances
but Jesus reminds us that the minimum
monthly payment on God's love has
already been taken care of and to
continue with the cliches let's think
about stuff for a minute do we own our
stuff or does stuff on us earthly stuff
is not all bad we just need to be
careful about where our money is going
and when all the stuff we have gathered
starts to take up more and more of our
time and energy then we can't spawn
spend that time and energy or money
serving God's people our hearts have
gone shopping instead have gone to God
you know what I mean buying something is
never really the end there's the
cleaning it the storing it the
schlepping it all around the country or
the world every time you move the
emotional pole stuff has on us just a
bit earlier in Matthew's Gospel where
your treasure is there your heart will
be also so as we work as we buy stuff as
we cash paychecks large or small as we
put one dollar into the offering plate
remember that God is the source of all
blessings we serve God by using our
material resources mindfully and wisely
and by sharing them with others this
perspective can free us from unnecessary
anxiety this perspective can free us not
to worry about our lives but show
concern and care for others lives the
gospel is not about being rich and poor
by the standards of this world it is
about knowing you are treasured by God
Jesus invites us to rest in that
knowledge to be honest about our worries
and try to entrust them
to God to remember that we cannot serve
God and money and to think carefully
about who or what we are serving can any
of you by worrying at a single hour to
your span of life if God is tending to
every petal of the lilies and every
feather of the birds of the air will not
God guard your life we do not know the
number of our days none of us do the
gospel calls us to live them every
single one of them knowing that God is
the source of all and sustains all so do
not worry about tomorrow for tomorrow
will bring worries of its own today is
at trouble and today's blessings will be
enough for today thanks be to God amen